[Musique]
je l'avais à boussé les restaurateurs je
n'ai jamais c'est un monde monsieur
jamais je suis allé le moment où je suis
moi chapatte milieu avait dirigé par
monsieur un avion militaire allemand
vient d'atterrir à lisbonne à son bord
huit médecins dix huit infirmières et
des appareils respiratoires des renforts
pour lutter contre la pandémie
jusqu'alors file au parlement juif vous
êtes un guignol mais parce que vous avez
dit restons ouverts et le jour j
peut-être fermer sinon passez vous
rendez compte du niveau du quai vous osé
venir ici me dvi x2 les messieurs à
cause de vous ces gens là vont rester
fermés mais vous êtes objets que vous
êtes vous avez un courage en carton ce
soir les frères tape dur sont de retour
les dupont et dupond de nous assurer que
cette aimable font peur je vous ai dit
comme mon chien nappe
il se met sous les dettes les chercheurs
ironie si sam ouvert ces chiffres nous
pourrions finir par nous y habituer
soyons cependant conscients qu'ils sont
très élevés et se traduisent par une
pression majeure et qui ne faiblit pas
sur nos structures hospitalières voulait
mettre tout le monde sous cloche bon je
pense qu'on va pas y échapper ouest vous
croyez ça j'ai sur moi alors je le
souhaite pas vous pensez avec ce qu'a
dit le président de la république entre
vendredi
moi je dis ce que le vary anglais va
faire [ __ ] en l'air c'est une
véritable enquête que les britanniques
viennent de lancer sur leur sol
il cherche la dernière mutation de leurs
virus
ils ont repéré sur 11 échantillons au
milieu de deux cent quatorze mille
prélèvements positifs
un nouveau rebondissement pour ce virus
anglais qui lui-même est une mutation du
virus de base
c'est pourquoi un nouveau confinement ne
peut s'envisager qu'en tout dernier
recours
la situation ne justifie pas à ce jour
notre niveau d'incidence est certes
élevé mais il reste encore très
inférieur à ce qu'il était en octobre
dernier
alors en attendant cette crise sanitaire
suscite aussi grogne sociale des
manifestations ont lieu aujourd'hui un
peu partout en france à l'appel de
plusieurs syndicats à les jeunes fous de
verser un revenu de solidarité jeunes
pendant les huit prochains mois
tel montant par exemple de 500 euros
[Applaudissements]
d'accord
présidents ministres collègues incidents
de séance mathilde panneaux a très vite
réclamé des sanctions contre ce député
qui crie la poissonnière
il s'agit d'un élu de la majorité pierre
oriet qui s'est excusé cette nuit sur
twitter mes chers collègues
on va continuer il ya encore deux
orateurs on va les écouter en fait on
procédera au vote
alors je demande aux uns et aux autres
d'écouter même panneau à l'assemblée
nationale on doit être exemplaire et
donc quand on se livre à ce type d'
insulte au sein de l'assemblée nationale
il faut qu'il ya une sanction qui sont
une sanction ferme et exemple à la
décision a été prise mi janvier
à partir du 1er février les députés
peuvent bénéficier de plus de 2800 euros
supplémentaires pour couvrir leurs frais
professionnels
vous avez une cinquantaine de députés
qui deux filles du confinement ont
multiplié les envois pour garder le lien
avec leur circonscription et ont
multiplié les envois postaux ils ont
dépassé cette enveloppe est donc les
questeurs ont fait une proposition de
dire vu le concert exceptionnel samedi
cette même un peu moins que 50 toujours
pas à comprendre ce que mes collègues et
prend quelques courants des papes et les
enveloppes ont pu faire pour dépenser
autant d'argent
comment être utile pas simplement être
candidat parce que c'est assez
c'est c'est le plus simple de dire qu'on
est candidat c'est d'apporter des
solutions
le pire appartement alors t'es pas du
monde en tout cas de new york qui fait
le buzz sur les réseaux sociaux
notamment sur tik tok basse et une
petite pièce up l'appartement que celle
des baraques c'est l'arrière cuisine
chez pas maintenant c'est l'appartement
voilà combien ça coûte 1605 francs par
mois